this is the car that brad pitt drove in
once upon a time in hollywood
[Music]
we are the largest movie car provider in
hollywood so there's a good chance if
you see a movie with a car in it it came
from our lot
my name is sean grogan i'm one of the
fabrication managers at cinema vehicles
we have about 100 cars on a lot anywhere
from police cars ambulances school buses
50s cars 40s cars 30s cars military
vehicles trailers taxi cabs prison buses
some of our cars are in pristine
condition some of them are crashed some
of them were burned i mean you name it
we have it on our lot
we've been in the business for over 40
years we've done tons of movies but some
of the ones you might recognize would be
gotten in 60 seconds
die hard
ant-man and the loss the avengers
spider-man 2
the hangover
mr mrs smith
rush hour and the list goes on and on
[Music]
in our shop we have an upholstery
department
we have a fabrication department
we have a mechanical department
paint and body department and a graphics
department
the way that it works is a production
company will call us and say they're
filming a new movie and they need x y
and z and they'll send us over basically
a drawing of what they want and then
it's our job to turn that drawing into
reality
[Music]
one of the challenges that we run into
is finding multiples of the same car so
one point in time we turned a chevy
silverado pickup into a rolls-royce for
the movie sorcerer's apprentice
we go to any one of a million sites
where you can find used vehicles they
don't have to be in running condition as
long as they look good and we can make
them run again that's the most important
part
once that vehicle comes in the shop
we'll have our design team do some
renderings and drawings and spec things
out from there the upholsterer will
change the seats maybe we'll add seat
covers maybe we'll add dash covers
once the upholstery shop is working on
their portion of it the fabrication team
is building custom parts
when the car is completed it'll go over
to our paint and body shop and from
there they will do all the bodywork
needed to make the car look like it's
pristine and then they'll go in and
they'll paint it
and then the mechanics will just check
the power train check fluids make sure
there's no leaks take it for a test
drive make sure the brakes are good but
make sure that when that car is on set
it doesn't break down
the last step is the graphics team will
print those logos up and then install
the graphics
and from there a production team will
come pick the cars up and then we don't
see them again until the movie shoot is
over
we're here in building c where we keep a
lot of our cars that need to stay
indoors
we have this lovely pontiac fire bird
with suicide doors from an old
commercial for uh kentucky fried chicken
i think it's finger licking gold or one
of my favorites is from from the movie
the hangover but they were painted brown
for another movie oh my god you ever
seen the show the agents of shield this
red corvette is lola
we are proud of the work that we do here
at cinema vehicles hollywood wouldn't
operate the way that it does without us
when we see our cars on the big screen
it's one of the most gratifying things
to see the finished product
[Music]